apple just made it extremely difficult
to choose which apple watch to buy
because they've not only added the brand
new ultra model into the lineup for the
first time ever but they've also reduced
the price of the apple watch se while
barely making any changes to the series
8. so in this video i'm going to stop
all of the confusion and explain all of
the main differences between them to
help you decide which apple watch to buy
and i'm going to give you guys some
advice that you're probably not
expecting so without further ado let's
jump right into it starting with the
biggest difference between all three
models the materials and sizes the apple
watch sc starts at 249 dollars and only
comes in aluminum in either midnight
starlight or silver with the smallest
case sizes either 40 or 44 millimeters
for 150 dollars more you can get the new
series 8 which comes in aluminum for the
base price and it gets an extra color
option product red and slightly larger
41 and 45 millimeter case sizes however
you can also get the series 8 in
stainless steel in either graphite
silver or gold but you'll have to pay at
least seven hundred dollars for these
and the price continues to go up based
on the band that you like and then
finally we have the brand new apple
watch ultra which is priced at the same
800
no matter which one of the new extreme
sports bands you choose which actually
makes it a killer value as i'm gonna
show you guys in just a minute but the
main thing you need to know is that it
only comes in the natural finish with
the now exclusive titanium chassis and
the massive 49 millimeter case size
which might actually be too large for
some people out there just look at this
side by side comparison right here as
well as how huge it looks on ijustine's
wrist now before this watch launched
there were some rumors floating around
saying that the existing watch bands
would not be compatible with this new
ultra model but thankfully you can also
use any 42 to 45 millimeter apple watch
band and that's actually perfect because
our sponsor juke sent us over some
custom made and designed apple watch
bands that are probably the highest
quality bands i've seen with stainless
steel butterfly clasps even on this one
which uses genuine italian leather from
a tannery in florence and the aluminum
bands like this onyx chrono are
extremely high quality yet incredibly
light including this ruby red vituro
band with custom engineered tapered
links for perfect curvature around the
wrist and juke even includes tools in
the box for adjustment with great
options for the ladies as well so check
them out in the description below now
getting back to the apple watch
differences the ultra has the biggest
display size and pixel density and it's
the only one that features a completely
flat sapphire crystal glass panel that's
actually protected by the titanium lip
compared to the other models with curved
and exposed glass the ultra also comes
with a completely unique design that's
rounded at first but then gets flat
towards the display and on the left side
it gets a new orange action button which
is customizable and unique to the ultra
while also featuring this large crown
guard that sticks out of the side
protecting the larger beefier crown and
this actually helps apple save room on
the inside of the watch itself allowing
apple to pack in a battery that's 76
percent larger than the one in the
series 8. and that leads to 36 hours of
battery life exactly double the amount
you get with both the series 8 and the
new se but it also makes the watch about
35 thicker than the other two and
surprisingly it's almost two times
heavier than the 44 millimeter se model
and about 19 heavier than the stainless
steel series 8. now believe it or not
but they all feature the same s8 chip
which is actually a rebranded s7 which
was already a rebranded s6 which is kind
of funny but i guess it means the chips
are fast enough for everything these
watches need to do the only difference
is that the se model doesn't come with
the u1 ultra wide band chip for precise
device tracking the se also doesn't get
features like the blood oxygen sensor
the electrical heart sensor the third
generation optical heart sensor fast
charging support the brand new
temperature sensing feature which is
available on both of the other models
for ovulation tracking ip6x
dust resistance and of course the se
doesn't get the always on display but to
be honest it still packs a majority of
the major features like car crash
detection 32 gigs of storage sleep
tracking support for the new compass and
backtrack features and more all for only
250 dollars and even more shocking you
only need to pay 50 dollars more to
upgrade to the cellular model making it
the absolute best choice if you're
buying an apple watch for your kid
instead of a more expensive iphone but
now let's dig into some of the things
that you can only get on the ultra
because it's really quite impressive
since this is meant to be an extreme
sports apple watch the ultra comes with
a display that can reach up to a massive
2000 nits of brightness which will
basically make the display easily
readable while in direct sunlight and it
also has the best water resistance at up
to 100 meters compared to 50 on the
other two in terms of durability and
weather proofing it's tested to the 810
h military standard and it's also the
only one that is certified for diving up
to 40 meters deep with the en
13319 certification which is the best
rating out there making it qualify as a
legit diving computer and apple even
gives you the exclusive oceanic plus
diving app for that alongside the new
depth gauge and water temperature sensor
features it also comes with precision
dual frequency gps with the added l5
band and it gets a new dual speaker
setup which is 40 louder than on the
series 8 allowing for the new siren
feature which i'm personally excited for
and it also gets a new 3 mic array with
beam forming for the best microphone
quality you can get it's also the only
apple watch that comes with bluetooth
5.3 to match the new iphone 14s and the
airpods pro 2 and of course it comes
with cellular built in at the base 800
price which i have to admit makes it the
best bang for the buck apple watch model
out there thanks to the massive 36 hours
of battery life and together with the
new low power mode the ultra can go up
to 60 hours on a single charge which is
actually really impressive and as a
little bonus it also gets a unique
braided usbc charging cable inside of
the really creative and high quality
packaging but now with all those
differences out of the way it's time to
get into my personal buyer's advice for
all of you guys out there including some
advice that you probably are not
expecting to hear from me if you're
currently looking at the series 8 apple
watch i would honestly recommend that
you stop and instead buy the series 7 on
amazon since you can find a renewed
model for as low as 317
or a brand new 45 millimeter model with
cellular for only 400 bucks and the
reason i'm making that recommendation is
because the series 8 really only has two
advantages over the seven it comes with
the car crash detection feature and
ovulation tracking and if that doesn't
matter that much to you then simply go
for the series seven now if you're
looking to spend even less cash like
let's say you're buying someone in apple
watch as a gift then the new se is
probably going to be the best option
since it packs most of the important
features for an incredibly low 250
dollar price however keep in mind that
it doesn't have an always on display
which might be important for the person
you're buying it for but let's say
you're buying it for a kid in that case
it's not gonna matter and it's a hundred
percent the model that i recommend for
kids but be sure to pay the extra fifty
dollars for the cellular model because
it's required for the kids setup feature
and then finally we have the ultra which
is in my opinion by far the best bang
for your buck in terms of how feature
packed and rugged it is especially with
double the battery life which is
basically the most important thing in
any battery-powered device it's also
something that's completely fresh and
new so it's probably going to be an
exciting choice for those who are
getting kind of bored of the general
apple watch design like myself and
that's honestly why i bought it but just
keep in mind that the 49 millimeter
chassis might look a little bit too big
for people with smaller wrists so you
might want to try it out at a nearby
apple store first if you live close to
one so there you guys go hopefully this
video helped you make a decision on
which apple watch model to buy and if it
did definitely check out juke's premium
apple watch bands down in the
description below and go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for our
hands-on comparison videos coming up
this weekend and check out one of those
two videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
you